Hollywood loves its sequels.
We're constantly bombarded with trailers,
posters, and concept art for franchise films.
But there are quite a few Part-Twos in the
works that have successfully stayed relatively
under the radar.
From Biblical epics to nineties nostalgia-fests,
let's take a look at some of the sequels you
didn't know were being made.
Edge of Tomorrow 2
The Groundhog Day of alien invasion movies,
2014's Edge of Tomorrow is one of the best
sci-fi films in recent memory.
Starring Tom Cruise and Emily Blunt, this
Doug Liman flick focuses on a cowardly major
who finds himself reliving the same day over
and over.
Unfortunately, that day involves an army of
extraterrestrials dead set on conquering Earth.
While the film earned rave reviews ...
“Have you ever felt this way before?”
… it was a major financial disappointment,
so it didn't seem like the Edge of Tomorrow
story would live to see another day.
But according to original screenwriter Christopher
McQuarrie, Cruise started pitching a sequel
while filming Mission Impossible: Rogue Nation.
Soon, the screenplay took shape and Blunt
and Liman were on-board for part two.
Sadly, Bill Paxton was also set to return
as the mustachioed Master Sergeant, but the
beloved actor passed away in February 2017.
Liman says the film will be a "sequel that's
a prequel," that is "going to revolutionize
how people make sequels."
Whatever that all means, it sounds like it
won't just be deja vu, all over again.
The Resurrection
With the success of Hacksaw Ridge, Mel Gibson
is enjoying something of a comeback.
And his next big project is a throwback to
his most successful film: 2004's The Passion
of the Christ.
Passion focused on the last hours of Jesus
Christ's life as he endured torture after
torture before his death on a cross.
Despite the unusually gory take on the well-known
tale, Passion became the highest-grossing
R-rated film in U.S. history.
In August 2016, Gibson announced he was working
on a sequel, a "huge undertaking" called The
Resurrection, with Braveheart scribe Randall
Wallace writing the screenplay.
In November, Gibson went on The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert and took a few questions
about the follow-up that he says is "likely
still three years out."
“No, no bad guys?”
“Well, there are.”
“Yeah?”
“They’re in another realm.”
“Oh.”
As Colbert notes, the bible does suggest Jesus
spent three days in hell, so it sounds like
Gibson might have the Messiah tangling with
some literal demons.
2020 can't get here fast enough.
The Equalizer 2
In 40 years of acting on the silver screen
Denzel Washington has never starred in a sequel.
But that's all about to change, as Washington
is set to revive Robert McCall, the literature-loving
hit man from 2014's The Equalizer.
Officially announced in April 2015, The Equalizer
2 is getting the band back together.
Washington, director Antoine Fuqua, and screenwriter
Richard Wenk are all back in action.
So why is Washington finally agreeing to a
sequel?
Producer Todd Black says the Jason Bourne
series inspired Denzel to finally take the
franchise plunge.
And he's not the only one on the project taking
big risks.
Black says Fuqua has a new "effect" planned,
which he can't talk about, but it's "frickin'
so cool you won't believe it."
Not even a hint, Dr. Evil?
“Throw me a frickin’ bone here!”
Guess we'll have to wait, but it sounds "frickin'"
amazing.
Look for The Equalizer 2 in 2018.
The Girl in the Spider's Web
David Fincher's 2011 adaptation of the Stieg
Larsson novel The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
didn't earn enough to impress studio executives,
so the next book in the series, The Girl Who
Played with Fire, never made it to the screen
in the U.S.
However, in November 2015, it was announced
that everybody's favorite hacker Lisbeth Salander
would finally return — only this time, Hollywood
would adapt The Girl in the Spider's Web,
the latest novel in the Millennium series,
written by David Lagercrantz after Larsson's
untimely death.
A year later, it was revealed that Spider's
Web will be helmed by Fede Alvarez, the director
behind Don't Breathe and the 2013 Evil Dead
reboot.
The studio also plans on recasting the lead
role, and rumor has it the producers are considering
Natalie Portman and Scarlett Johansson, among
others.
Spider's Web is scheduled to hit theaters
October 2018.
The Rocketeers
Released in 1991 between Robin Hood: Prince
of Thieves and Terminator 2: Judgment Day,
the two highest-grossing movies of the year,
The Rocketeer crashed and burned at the box
office.
killing Disney's hope of establishing an Indiana
Jones-style franchise.
But over the years, this World War II-era
adventure has picked up something of a cult
following, inspiring the studio to finally
revisit The Rocketeer universe.
In July 2016, Disney finally announced The
Rocketeers, a follow-up taking place about
six years after the events of the original
film.
Our new Rocketeer — yet to be cast — is
an African-American female pilot who finds
herself in the middle of some serious Cold
War intrigue with an evil rocket scientist
trying to get his hands on the all-powerful
jetpack.
Interestingly, the film is being co-produced
by NBA star Blake Griffin, who must have a
thing for rocket packs, considering he sported
one in that Gamefly spot …
“Do you guys have a bathroom?
Thank you!”
Hopefully he'll have a cameo.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love, too!